what's going on guys this is rob blah
blah pop culture explained to intro okay
so one division episode number eight was
amazing here's the thing about the
mid-credits scene
doesn't really matter right the
mid-credits scene is a reference to the
event in the comics where vision was
basically destroyed and then recreated
so the idea
in marvel comics is that vision's brain
patterns how he thinks and all that kind
of stuff was based off a superhero named
simon williams and so that avenger
ultimately when he died vision died
shortly after somewhere around that
period and then vision was rebuilt but
because of the fact that he lost his
mental patterns what you can basically
call machine version of amnesia he
essentially just popped back up is like
a full
white version of vision right most
likely what's gonna happen he's gonna go
into wanda vision he's gonna face off
against wanda and whatever it's
sword's first time experimenting with
like a sentient weapon right that's
really all that is so get into the meat
and potatoes of this right let's talk
about wanda let's talk about agatha
let's talk about the concept of chaos
magic what does this mean okay let's
explain magic
those of you guys who have seen my
agatha harkness explained video on
comics explained which exploded last
week when that episode
ended but that video will make you an
expert on agatha harkness in about 15
minutes but if you want the
the short and gritty of it there's
different kinds of magic in marvel
comics right so let's take
agatha's version of magic and then let's
take wanda's version of magic because
wanda's magical ability
is for the most part the exact same as
doctor strange if they do what i think
they're gonna do so what you have here
are individuals like agatha who
manipulate what's called
ambient magical energy an ambient
magical energy is basically just the
energy that makes up the universe right
now it does not mean
that she's equal to like an infinity
stone that's not what that means all it
simply means is that the universe itself
permeates with energy and that there are
some individuals out there
like dr doom's mom cynthia von doom who
was able to do it after selling her soul
to mephisto or somebody like agatha
harkness they're able to tap into that
ambient magical energy and then use it
for their own ants by all standards of
measurement there's no true
differentiation between
how agatha uses their powers and how
doctor strange uses his powers the only
difference is the potency of their
spells
the ability for agatha to manipulate
reality on a universal scale
doesn't really exist doctor strange he
can't because agatha cannot manipulate
the same kind of magic that dr strange
can what doctor strange does
and what wanda do is they basically
borrow the powers of
others what doctor strange does is he
uses the powers of individuals like
sidorak for example sidorak being the
guy who made the juggernaut into the
juggernaut those of you guys who are
familiar with like the fox x-men movies
where you saw like deadpool 2 and you
had that huge
gargantuan guy walking around the
deadpool that's juggernaut right citarat
created a stone he put it on earth and
is called the crimson gem of sidorak
doctor strange used the crimson bands of
sidorak
in avengers infinity war when he shot
those red ribbons out of himself and
then bonded them to thanos what
wanda is doing here is manipulating
something called chaos magic why does
this matter okay
those of you guys who are circulating
around the idea of wanda being a nexus
being i think you're right but i think
you're right to a degree right so the
idea in marvel comics is you have a guy
by the name of
catholic the nature of catholic is that
he's what's called an elder god and
catholic was a elder god who occupied
earth before the purging of the elder
gods happened and so when that purge
happened and you basically had all these
different elder gods being eliminated
and destroyed that catholic
and don't get this wrong he was evil he
was a terrible guy but catholic took all
of his knowledge of dark magic
and he wrote it down on basically pieces
of flesh right human flesh which is
pretty messed up and pretty gruesome
when you think about it um about 30
000 years before the present day a woman
named morgan lafaye took those
pieces of flesh and then just copied all
the texts down into a book which became
known as the darkhold but the whole
point behind this is that cathone is
super powerful now this is where things
get crazy in marvel comics it was
prophesied that somebody out there would
be born with the ability the inherent
ability to manipulate chaos magic now
for scholar which it was not necessarily
inherent when she was born into the
world she was touched by catholic who
basically granted her a portion of his
power but the reason why that happened
is because according to the prophecy
that individual who's able to wield
chaos magic will in turn
serve as a vector by which cathode can
leave his plane of existence and enter
into the earthly realm basically into
the universe and then conquer it right
or do whatever it is that he ends up you
know intends to do
and that's what it looks like is
happening with wanda but that's assuming
the marvel cinematic universe wants to
go in that direction
something to understand here is that the
mcu is based on
basically three types of marvel
franchises right you have the ultimate
universe which was lost in 2000 and that
was the answer to the question what
would happen or what would it look like
if superheroes existed like right now if
they came into existence right now
at the time that series was launched
then you have earth 98 which is a
universe in marvel comics where
superheroes age in real time
and then you have the marvel main marvel
universe where almost all the marvel
stories you've ever read have been told
and so because of that
a lot of things get shifted around right
it's kind of the nature of the marvel
rule right you got occam's razor you've
got hanlon's law you got murphy's law
all that kind of stuff you got the mcu
rule right the simplest plot
tends to be the right one and so because
of that it's one of these things where
it could be
it could be something as simple as the
idea that the term chaos magic
is not necessarily designed to
illustrate that wanda
is using chaos magic which inherently
belongs to cathode and she's going to
serve as a means by which cathode can
leave his realm and show up on earth it
simply
may just be an indication that like
chaos magic just manifests in random
ways
and it's just kind of weird and wonky
and kind of crazy and that's basically
it
given the severity of the situation and
giving given how much
knowledge of magic agatha seems to have
over the course of the last 300
some odd years that she's been alive i
would lean more towards the idea
that wanda is absurdly powerful in
wielding chaos magic but the question is
what can she do with this all right
here's the thing to understand the
ability to wield chaos magic is
basically a limitless source of energy
what you've seen wanda do
in wandavision isn't even the beginning
of the tip of the iceberg she can alter
the very fabric of the universe itself
right we saw the full totality of what
wanda could do
during the events of house of m and this
is why things are significant right we
saw the full totality of what she could
do in the events of house of m
when you basically had wanda taking away
98 of the mutant population's powers but
the reason why that mattered is because
in a future story it was revealed she
did it across the entirety of the
multiverse not just her own native
universe and that's why doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness that's why
the events
of one division all basically seem to
tie together that if wanda if if all
this pops off and
and whatever this ending happens to take
right something bad happens her kids are
like destroyed or kids were never real
and wanna just freak right because i
have to believe given what we've seen so
far right wanda was pushed to her
breaking point
after losing her parents and after
losing her brother and then after losing
vision that's how we got from point a to
point b
and that the way her powers were
bolstered and she's just been using
chaos magic ever since then in turn like
she loses her kids or maybe like steven
strange
right steven strange shows up at the end
of the series and is like wanda your
kids aren't real right like none of this
is real like when you have that that
what is it that line from vision and the
various tv spots we've seen where it's
like well this is our world let's fight
for it and so like wanda fights for she
defeats agatha harkness the day saves
she gets to continue living the life
that she always wanted to live and then
here comes stephen strange one of this
has to stop and she's like enough is
enough right and she just fully lets
loose over chaos magic and then it just
kind of permeates and goes nuts maybe
cathode shows up who knows but whatever
it is it'll go into wanda
i think being the main villain and
doctor strange multiverse of madness
right i think this is how wanda becomes
a bad guy i think either she gets
completely and totally corrupted by her
power she's possessed by cathode in his
entirety
assuming he exists right i mean that's
one of the things the ancient one
pointed out and doctor strange right she
said like there have been countless
there are countless threats out there
right there are countless threats that
exist out there and if i told you all
the different horrors that existed you
go running screaming from this place
right so it stands to reason to believe
that like catholic does exist out there
right and maybe at some point on the
line he was defeated and locked away by
the ancient one whatever the case is
but this allows him to basically return
possesses wanda goes forward in doctor
strange multiverse of madness and
wanda's the bad guy that's my kind of
thought on this but again like this
episode was really more about the
backstory of wanda right it was more
about answering the question how did we
get from a girl who can
read minds and move objects with her
mind to a girl that could like alter
reality even if only in a localized
space and then completely restructure
matter but the big takeaway from this
and the sense that you can use chaos
magic is
the powers of wanda are limitless there
is no finite limit to what she can do
presumably she can kill and take over
anybody right she's
way beyond doctor strange at this point
right like she's so far beyond doctor
strange it's not even funny it's kind of
nuts
i would surmise probably in the
multiverse of madness you might even see
the living tribunal pop up that wanda
creates an inherent imbalance of magical
energy inside
her own universe and across the
multiverse and the living tribunal
basically says
nope because of that like i exist to
safeguard balance across the multiverse
you are creating an imbalance
in that multiverse gotta go and then
that's the end of wanda right because if
you think she's powerful
she's got nothing on the living tribunal
even if she is manipulating chaos magic
the living tribunal this is a guy who
could just
snap his fingers and wanda just ceases
to exist right i mean this the power of
the living tribunal is insane i really
hope we get to see him in the marvel
cinematic universe i don't know if
that'll happen
but if we do it would be amazing but
anyway guys thanks for watching if you
guys want to see more of our theories
and discussions on one division make
sure you hit the playlist and make sure
you check out comics explained for my
videos on agatha the hardness explained
uh nightmare explained the darkhold
explained all that kind of stuff and i
guess now i should probably make a video
on like chaos magic explained so anyway
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
and i will catch you all later
peace